- Maligayang pagbabalik sa Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
Ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at
ako ang technical director para sa IBM Quantum Education.
Ito ang ika-anim na aralin ng serye at ito ang pangalawang aralin sa
ikalawang unit ng serye, na tungkol sa quantum algorithms.
Sa nakaraang aralin, tinalakay natin ang query
model ng computation, at nakita natin na sa modelong iyon, ang quantum algorithms ay maaaring magbigay ng kapansin-pansing kalamangan
laban sa mga classical algorithms, kasama na ang exponential na kalamangan sa kaso ng Simon's problem.
Sa kasamaang palad, ang query
model ay walang direkta o agarang
praktikal na kaugnayan.
Ang konsepto ng black box ay isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na
abstraksiyon tulad ng lumalabas, ngunit mayroon tayong trabaho na
gagawin kung gusto nating ilapat
ang mga pananaw na ating
nakuha mula sa query model sa mas karaniwang computational na kapaligiran kung saan ang mga input ay ibinibigay bilang mga string ng bits
sa halip na bilang mga oracle o black box.
Ang pangunahing layunin ng araling ito ay magtatag ng pundasyon
kung saan natin magagawa iyon.
Narito ang pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin. Sa malaking bahagi ng aralin, magtutuon tayo
sa computational na gastos,
o sa madaling salita, kung gaano kahirap ang iba't ibang
computational na gawain at kung paano natin masusukat ang hirap na iyon.
Sa simpleng pagsasalita, ito ay nagsasalin sa kung gaano katagal nating hihintayin
para matapos ang mga computations at sa huli kung aling mga
computational na problema
ang ating malulutas at kung aling
mga ito ang lampas sa ating kakayahan.
Magsisimula tayo sa
ilang halimbawa. Ang integer factorization at computing greatest common
divisors o GCDs para sa maikli.
Ang mga ito ay napakagandang halimbawa para sa paglalarawan ng
mga pangunahing prinsipyo, at parehong may kaugnayan din
sa Shor's algorithm, na tatalakayin natin sa susunod na aralin,
kaya makakakuha tayo ng doble ang kagalingan sa mga halimbawang ito.
Pagkatapos, tatalakayin natin ang konsepto ng computational na gastos nang mas pangkalahatan at kung paano natin ito masusukat.
Maraming iba't ibang
paraan na magagawa ito, ngunit magtutuon tayo nang medyo
makitid sa kung paano natin magagawa ito gamit ang circuit models ng computation,
partikular ang Boolean circuits
at quantum circuits.
Ang pokus dito ay magiging sa algorithms kumpara sa computer
hardware, halimbawa, at mas mabibigyang-halaga natin
kung paano nagbe-scale ang mga gastos ng
pagpapatakbo ng isang algorithm habang lumalaki ang mga partikular na instansya ng problema kaysa sa kung ilang segundo,
minuto, o oras ang kinakailangan ng ilang
partikular na computation.
Ang ideyang nagbibigay-motibasyon sa pananaw na ito ay ang mga algorithm ay may
pundamental na kahalagahan.
Hanggang ngayon, tayo ay
nagpapatakbo pa rin ng mga algorithm na binuo nang
napakatagal na ang nakakaraan at napaka-natural, sila ay ide-deploy
laban sa mas malalaki at
mas malalaking instansya ng problema gamit ang mas mabilis at mas maaasahang hardware habang umuunlad ang teknolohiya.
At ang paraan ng kanilang pag-scale ay nagsasabi sa atin ng marami
tungkol sa kung gaano sila kapaki-pakinabang at kung gaano sila magiging kapaki-pakinabang.
Sa huling bahagi ng aralin, magtutuon tayo sa isang kritikal na mahalagang gawain, na ang pagpapatakbo ng mga classical computations
sa mga quantum computers. Ang dahilan kung bakit ito mahalaga ay hindi dahil umaasa tayo na palitan ang mga classical computers
ng mga quantum computers,
na mukhang napaka-imposible na mangyari sa malapit na hinaharap kung mangyayari man ito, kundi dahil nagbubukas ito
ng maraming kawili-wiling posibilidad
para sa mga quantum algorithms.
Partikular, kapag nalaman na natin kung paano magpatakbo ng mga classical computations
sa mga quantum computers, nagiging available ang mga ito sa mga quantum
algorithms bilang mga subroutine
kaya maaari tayong epektibong
gamitin ang lahat ng alam natin tungkol sa mga classical algorithms sa paghahanap ng mga quantum computational na kalamangan.
Ang mga classical computers na mayroon tayo ngayon ay tunay na mga kahanga-hangang teknolohiya.
Sila ay hindi kapani-paniwalang mabilis, ngunit hindi sila napakabilis na walang computational na problema
na lampas sa kanilang kakayahan.
Ang ilang mga computational na problema
ay napaka-likas na mahirap kaya kahit mayroon tayong
mga algorithm para malutas ang mga ito, walang computer sa buong mundo ngayon
ang sapat na mabilis para patakbuhin ang mga
algorithm na ito hanggang sa katapusan kahit sa medyum na laki na mga input sa loob ng habang-buhay ng isang tao
o kahit sa loob ng
buhay ng Mundo mismo.
Para ipaliwanag pa, tingnan natin ang
integer factorization problem.
Ang pahayag ng problema ay napaka-simple. Ang input sa problema ay isang integer N na hindi bababa sa dalawa, at ang output ay ang
prime factorization ng N,
at ang ibig sabihin niyon ay isang listahan ng mga prime number na salik ng N kasama ang mga potensya na dapat itaas ng mga prime number na ito
upang makuha ang N sa pamamagitan ng
pagpaparami ng lahat ng ito.
Siyempre, maaari nating palaging paramihin ang mga prime factor nang magkasama sa anumang pagkakasunud-sunod, ngunit bukod sa kanilang pagkakasunud-sunod,
ang mga prime factorization ay palaging natatangi para sa bawat pagpipilian ng N.
Ang katotohanang iyon ay tinatawag na
fundamental theorem of arithmetic, at kung interesado kang
matuto nang higit pa tungkol dito, ito ay isang bagay na mahahanap mo
sa simula ng
maraming libro sa number theory.
Bilang napaka-simpleng halimbawa, narito ang prime factorization
ng bilang na 12.
Ito ay dalawa sa kapangyarihang dalawa
times tatlo sa kapangyarihang isa.
Hindi nakakagulat, ang
computer ay makakapagsabi sa iyo nito sa isang kisap-mata sa pamamagitan lamang ng iterative na paghahanap
para sa mga prime factor.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa. Hindi ko susubukang basahin ang numerong ito.
Ito ay humigit-kumulang 3.4 quattuordecillion, at kailangan kong aminin na nakakapagtaka sa akin na may ganitong pangalan,
ngunit gayunpaman, ito ay may 46 na decimal digits at dito makikita mo
ang prime factorization nito.
Kaya rin iyon sabihin ng isang computer. Na-factor ko ang numerong ito gamit ang factoring method na kasama sa symbolic mathematics
library para sa Python,
at ito ay tumagal ng ilang segundo, na hindi naman partikular na matagal, ngunit may kapansin-pansing pagkaantala.
At tiyak na ang factor N method ay hindi nakakakita ng prime factorization na ito sa pamamagitan ng simpleng paghahanap para sa mga prime factor.
Gumagamit talaga ito ng hybrid
ng iba't ibang algorithms kasama na ang isa na tinatawag na
colored row algorithm, na isang algorithm para sa factoring
na mas sopistikado kaysa sa simpleng iterative na paghahanap
para sa mga prime factor, at kahit mukhang malaking numero iyon,
bilang input sa isang computational na problema, hindi naman ito masyadong malaki.
Ito ay 46 character lamang.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa. Ito ay isang numero na may 309 decimal digits.
Kung isusulat natin ito sa binary notation, ito ay may 1,024 bits at iyon ang
dahilan kung bakit ito ay tinatawag na RSA1024.
Ang prime factorization ng numerong ito ay hindi pa kilala sa kasalukuyan.
Ang numerong ito ay nagmula sa
RSA factoring challenge, na pinapatakbo ng RSA
Laboratories mula 1991 hanggang 2007.
Nag-alok sila ng cash prizes
para sa mga prime factorization ng iba't ibang numero ng lumalaking
laki, kasama na ang isang ito, na nagkakahalaga ng $100,000 US,
ngunit hindi kailanman natanggap ang premyong iyon.
Ang seguridad ng RSA
public key crypto system ay batay sa kahirapan
ng integer factorization.
Kung kaya mong mag-factor, kaya
mong masira ang sistema, kaya ang layunin ng hamon ay karaniwang subaybayan ang
estado ng sining sa factoring.
Ang resulta ay ang
pag-factor ng numerong ito ay lampas sa ating kasalukuyang kakayahan.
Ayon sa alam natin, ang
problema mismo ay masyadong kumplikado para malutas ng mga classical computers
sa praktis.
Ang pinakamalaking RSA challenge number na na-factor na, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ay may 250 decimal digits.
Maaaring medyo mahirap itong
basahin sa screen, ngunit narito ang prime
factorization ng RSA250.
Ito ay ginawa noong 2020 gamit ang isang algorithm na kilala bilang number field sieve, at ito ay isang kolektibong pagsisikap na kinasangkutan ng sampung libo
ng mga computer sa buong mundo.
Ngayon, isaalang-alang natin ang ibang
computational na problema, na ang problema ng pag-compute ng greatest common
divisor, o GCD para sa maikli,
ng dalawang hindi-negatibong integer.
Narito ang pahayag ng problema. Ang input ay binubuo ng dalawang
numero sa pagkakataong ito, N at M,
at ipagpalagay nating
hindi parehong katumbas ng zero.
Ang layunin ay i-compute ang
GCD ng dalawang numerong ito, na ang pinakamalaking integer D na pantay na hahatiin sa parehong N at M,
at kung iniisip mo ang
mga prime factorization ng N at M, makikita mo na ang GCD ay ang produkto ng lahat ng prime numbers
na hahatiin sa parehong N at M na itataas sa minimum ng mga kapangyarihang lumalabas sa dalawang
prime factorization.
Kaya may kaugnayan ito sa problema
ng integer factorization, ngunit lumalabas na ito ay mas, mas madali
para sa mga computer na malutas. Maaari nating i-compute ang mga GCD para sa mga numero na may libu-libong digits
sa isang kisap-mata.
Magiging walang saysay para sa akin na subukang ipakita sa iyo ang mga halimbawa sa screen dahil mapupuno natin ang buong screen ng mga digits at mailarawan pa rin natin ang
madaling nalulutas na mga instansya ng problemang ito.
Ngunit kung interesado ka, sundin ang link sa paglalarawan ng video sa pahina ng textbook para sa araling ito at makikita mo ang mga code cell
para sa mga uri ng computations
na pinag-uusapan ko, kasama na ang mga nagko-compute
ng mga GCD ng malalaking numero, at maaari mong subukan ang mga ito para sa iyong sarili.
Ang tanong ay bakit posibleng mag-compute ng mga GCD nang napakadali?
At ang sagot sa tanong na iyon ay mayroon tayong efficient na
mga algorithm para mag-compute ng mga GCD.
Kabilang sa mga ito ang Euclid's algorithm, na natuklasan nang higit sa 2,000 taon na ang nakakaraan, ngunit mayroon ding iba pang
efficient na GCD algorithms.
At siyempre, pag-uusapan natin ang mga classical algorithms dito, kaya humahantong ito sa isa pang tanong.
Maaari bang mayroon
classical na algorithm para sa integer factorization
na magbibigay-daan sa atin na mag-factor ng mga numero tulad ng RSA1024
sa isang kisap-mata?
At ang sagot ay oo. Talagang maaaring mayroon ngang efficient na classical
algorithm para sa factoring at kasalukuyan ay hindi natin alam ang anumang paraan
para ibukod ang posibilidad na iyon. Ang lahat ng masasabi natin ay
hindi pa natin ito natagpuan.
Para sa lahat ng classical
factoring algorithms na alam natin, tayo ay mahalagang
naghahanap pa rin ng mga salik
at iyon ay naglalagay ng mga numero tulad ng
RSA1024 sa labas ng ating kakayahan.
Ang mga efficient na GCD algorithms,
sa kabilang banda, ay hindi gayon ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho.
Hindi sila naghahanap ng
greatest common divisor. Epektibo silang nagtatayo lang
nito gamit ang isang mekanikal na pamamaraan na halos kapareho ng gastos
ng pagpaparami ng dalawang
numero nang magkasama, at sasabihin ko pa nang kaunti tungkol dito mamaya sa aralin.
Siyempre, lahat ito ay nagtatayo
para sa Shor's algorithm, na makikita natin sa susunod na aralin, na isang efficient na quantum algorithm
para sa pag-compute ng mga prime factorization, ngunit mayroon pa tayong sakop na lupa bago tayo makarating doon.
Susunod, pag-uusapan natin
ang isang mathematical framework kung saan maaari nating masukat ang mga computational na gastos
ng iba't ibang algorithm,
kasama na ang mga napag-usapan na natin.
Para maging malinaw, magtutuon tayo nang medyo makitid sa mga circuit, na isang maliit na piraso lamang
ng mas malawak na paksa.
Magsimula tayo sa isang mataas na antas na pananaw ng isang karaniwang computation
mula sa nakaraang aralin, ibig sabihin, partikular na hindi tayo nag-iisip
tungkol sa mga query problem,
nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa
mga problema kung saan ang input ay ibinibigay nang hayagan bilang isang binary string.
Tulad ng sinabi ko sa nakaraang aralin, maaari siyempre tayong magpahintulot ng
iba pang mga simbolo kung gusto natin, ngunit panatilihin nating simple at manatili sa mga binary string
para sa parehong input at output.
Ang computation mismo ay maaaring model o ilarawan sa iba't ibang paraan tulad ng Turing
machine model ng computation,
Boolean circuits, quantum circuits, o mga program na nakasulat sa
isang wika tulad ng Python o anumang iba pang wikang gusto mo.
Tulad ng sinabi ko kanina, magtutuon tayo sa
mga circuit, Boolean at quantum.
Una, gumastos tayo ng kaunting oras sa pag-usapan ang input at output, na ipinapalagay nating mga binary string.
Gamit ang mga binary string, maaari nating i-encode ang maraming iba't ibang uri ng
mga mathematical na bagay, tulad ng mga numero, vector,
matrices, graphs,
mga paglalarawan ng mga molekula, halimbawa, pati na rin ang mga listahan ng lahat ng mga bagay na ito at iba pa.
Bilang napaka-simpleng halimbawa, kung gusto nating i-encode ang mga hindi-negatibong
integer bilang mga binary string, maaari tayong gumamit ng binary notation.
Dito sa talahanayan na ito, makikita mo ang unang 13
hindi-negatibong integer kasama ang kanilang mga binary
representasyon o encoding.
Dito sa ikatlong hanay, makikita mo ang haba ng
bawat isa sa mga encoding na ito, na ang kabuuang bilang ng bits na kailangan mo para sa encoding,
at narito ang isang simpleng formula na nagsasabi sa iyo nang eksakto kung ilang bits
ang kailangan sa pangkalahatan para sa anumang hindi-negatibong integer N.
Pansinin lalo na na
ang haba ng encoding ay karaniwang mas maikli
kaysa sa numero mismo.
Ito ay logarithmic sa numero.
RSA1024 halimbawa, ay may encoding na may haba na 1,024, ngunit ang numero mismo ay
siyempre mas malaki kaysa doon.
Ang encoding scheme na ito ay gumagana
para sa mga hindi-negatibong integer, ngunit kung gusto nating pangasiwaan ang
mga arbitrary na integer, kasama na ang mga negatibo, maaari tayong maglagay lamang ng sign bit.
Maaari rin tayong magpahintulot ng anumang bilang ng mga nangunguna na zero sa mga encoding na ito kung gusto nating punan ng mga encoding
ang isang bloke ng bits o isang register ng fixed na laki
basta sapat na ang laki. Minsan iyon ay napaka-maginhawa.
Hindi ito ang tanging paraan para i-encode ang mga integer bilang mga string ng bits.
Mayroon pang iba pang paraan na magagawa mo ito, ngunit ito ay isang medyo
karaniwang paraan para gawin ito.
Para sa iba pang uri ng mga bagay na maaaring bumuo ng mga input o output sa mga computational
na problema na interesado tayo, maaari tayong makagawa ng
iba pang encoding schemes.
Halimbawa, isipin kung paano mo
i-encode ang isang vector o isang graph bilang isang binary string o isipin kung paano mo i-encode
ang dalawang binary string sa
isang binary string gamit lamang ang simbolong zero at isa nang walang espasyo o anumang iba pang simbolo
para paghiwalayin ang dalawang string. Tiyak na may mga paraan para
gawin ang mga bagay na ito, at sa katunayan, mayroon tayong maraming kalayaan
sa kung paano natin ito gagawin.
Kadalasan ay walang iisang karaniwang o unibersalmente napagkasunduang paraan para i-encode ang anumang bagay na pinag-uusapan natin
bilang isang binary string,
ngunit okay lang iyon, maaari lang tayong pumili ng isa o maaari tayong mag-imbento ng bago kung gusto natin.
Mula sa pormal na pananaw, itinuturing natin ang mga computation bilang mahalagang mekanikal na mga pagbabago sa mga string ng bits
at ang mga partikular ng anumang
encoding scheme na ginagamit natin ay tiyak na mahalaga sa ilang antas.
Ngunit gayunpaman, kapag nagdidisenyo at
nag-aanalisa ng mga algorithm, karaniwang hindi tayo masyadong nag-aalala tungkol sa mga partikular ng
mga encoding scheme.
Kung hihilingin mo sa dalawang tao na makagawa ng paraan para i-encode, sabihin nating, mga molekula ng isang tiyak na
uri bilang mga binary string,
maaari mong asahan na makagawa sila ng iba't ibang paraan para gawin ito, ngunit kung ang mga ito ay makatwirang mga tao na nakaalam ng ginagawa nila,
maaari rin nating makatwirang asahan na ito ay magiging medyo
simpleng computational na proseso para isalin nang pabalik-balik sa pagitan ng dalawang encoding scheme,
malamang na nangangailangan ng napaka-
tuwid na computation na magiging medyo madali kumpara sa aktwal na computation
na interesado tayo.
Ang resulta ay ang mga detalye tungkol sa mga encoding scheme na ginagamit natin ay kadalasang pangalawang-daan at ang ating pokus ay sa
mga algorithm mismo.
Wala ito sa magiging isyu para sa araling ito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan. Kadalasan magtutuon tayo sa mga problema na tungkol sa mga integer, na ipagpapalagay nating naka-encode sa binary,
ngunit ito ay isang bagay na dapat malaman.
Sa pangkalahatan, para sa anumang uri ng problema na pinag-uusapan natin, ang haba ng input ay tumutukoy
sa bilang ng bits na kailangan natin para i-encode ang input,
at tinitingnan natin ang haba ng input bilang laki ng instansya ng anumang problema na iniisip natin.
Ngayon, isaalang-alang natin
ang computation mismo, na kinakatawan ng
asul na parihaba sa figure na ito.
Ang paraan ng ating pagsukat
ng gastos ng computation na ito ay bibilangin ang bilang ng mga elementary na operasyon na kailangan nito.
Sa madaling salita, ang isang elementary na operasyon ay isa na kinasasangkutan ng maliit na fixed na
bilang ng mga bit o qubit
na maaaring isagawa nang mabilis at madali tulad ng pag-compute ng AND ng
dalawang bit, halimbawa.
Sa pormal na antas,
mayroong iba't ibang paraan para tukuyin kung ano ang isang elementary na operasyon, depende sa kung anong
computational model ang ginagamit natin.
Halimbawa, ang isang elementary na operasyon ay maaaring isang hakbang ng isang Turing machine kung ginagamit natin ang modelong iyon.
Para sa mga layunin ng araling ito, magtutuon tayo sa mga circuit model, tulad ng nasabi ko na, at partikular na ang quantum
at Boolean circuits.
Kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa mga circuit, karaniwang iniisip natin ang bawat gate bilang kumakatawan sa isang elementary na operasyon.
Nakakita tayo ng ilang iba't ibang quantum gate hanggang ngayon sa serye,
kasama na ang X, Y at Z gates, Hadamard gates, S at T gates,
controlled NOT gates, swap gates, Toffoli gates, at Fredkin gates.
Napag-usapan din natin ang mga query gate sa konteksto ng query model, ngunit hindi tayo magtatrabaho sa loob ng query model sa araling ito, kaya hindi na tayo mag-aalala tungkol sa
mga query gate sa ngayon.
Nakita rin natin na ang anumang unitary na operasyon sa anumang bilang ng mga qubit
ay maaaring tiningnan bilang isang gate kung gusto natin.
Para sa mga layunin ng pagsukat ng gastos, gayunpaman, iyon ay hindi magiging napakakatulong, kaya ang gagawin natin ay pipili lang tayo ng isang hanay ng mga gate
at ituturing natin ang hanay na iyon bilang ating hanay ng mga elementary na operasyon.
Una, isasama natin ang
mga single qubit unitary gate na makikita mo dito,
partikular ang X, Y at Z gates,
Hadamard gates at S at T gates, pati na rin ang kanilang mga inverse
o conjugate transposes.
Hindi natin kailangan ang lahat ng mga gate na ito. Kapag mayroon na tayong Hadamard at T gates, maaari nating ipatupad ang natitirang mga ito,
ngunit para sa kaginhawahan lamang, isasama natin ang lahat ng mga ito.
Isasama rin natin ang mga controlled NOT gate, at ang mga ito ang magiging tanging
multiple qubit gate sa ating hanay.
At sa wakas, isasama natin ang mga single-qubit standard basis measurement para makapagkuha tayo ng ilang classical na impormasyon
na lumalabas sa ating mga circuit.
Kung magtuon tayo sa mga unitary gate at kalimutan ang tungkol sa
mga measurement saglit, makukuha natin ang tinatawag na
isang universal gate set.
Ang ibig sabihin niyon ay
ang anumang unitary na operasyon sa anumang bilang ng mga qubit ay maaaring
ipatupad nang eksakto
o arbitrarily malapit
gamit ang isang quantum circuit na binuo mula sa mga gate na ito lamang.
Sa madaling salita, ito ay isang
sapat na magandang hanay ng mga gate na maaari nating itayo ang anumang unitary
na operasyon mula sa mga ito.
Hindi kinakailangang eksakto, ngunit maaari tayong makakuha ng kasinghalaga ng approximation na gusto natin.
Iyon ay maaaring nangangailangan ng maraming gate, at talagang hindi napakahirap na dahilan na kailangan nito ng maraming gate sa ilang pagkakataon,
ngunit gayunpaman, lagi itong posible.
Hindi simpleng bagay ang patunayan na ito ay isang universal gate set, at hindi natin tatalakayin kung paano
ito ginagawa sa serye,
ngunit ito ay isang medyo kilalang katotohanan at mayroon ding iba't ibang
paraan na maaaring mapatunayan ito.
Mayroon ding iba pang mga gate set na kung minsan ay ginagamit
sa halip ng ito, tulad ng mga Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate, at S gate kasama ang mga measurement,
ngunit ito ay isang medyo karaniwang pagpipilian.
Kaya sa buod, ito ang
mga quantum na operasyon na ituturing nating elementary.
Para sa mga Boolean circuit,
ituturing nating elementary ang apat na gate na ito: AND gates, OR gates, NOT gates at FANOUT.
Ang FANOUT, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ay hindi
laging binibilang bilang isang gate, ngunit mahalaga para sa atin na gawin ito tulad ng makikita natin mamaya sa aralin.
Katulad ng sa ating
standard quantum gate set, ang hanay na ito ay medyo redundant.
Hindi mo kailangan ang parehong AND at OR. Maaari kang lumikha ng alinman gamit ang isa pa gamit ang tatlong NOT gate,
ngunit hindi masakit na isama ang parehong at maginhawa lang ito.
Tulad ng maaaring alam mo na, ito ay isang universal gate set
para sa mga deterministic na computation, ibig sabihin, anumang function
mula sa bits hanggang bits
ay maaaring ipatupad gamit ang isang Boolean circuit na binubuo ng mga gate mula sa koleksyong ito.
Muli, tulad ng sa
mga quantum circuit, hindi ito nangangahulugang ang bawat function ay maaaring ipatupad nang mahusay
ng isang Boolean circuit,
at sa katunayan, karamihan sa mga function
ay maaari lamang ipatupad gamit ang napakalaking mga circuit
para sa simpleng dahilan na mayroon maraming maraming function
at hindi lahat sila ay maaaring magkaroon ng maliliit na circuit. Walang sapat na
maliliit na circuit para sa lahat.
Ang universality ay mas madaling
patunayan sa kasong ito kaysa sa quantum na kaso tulad ng lumalabas.
Kaya kung hindi mo pa alam
kung paano ito patunayan, pag-isipan ito at
tingnan kung maisasagawa mo ito kung gusto mo.
Ngayong napagdesyunan na natin ang
mga gate na papayagan natin at ituturing nating
elementary na operasyon, maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa kung ilan sa kanila
ang kinakailangan para magsagawa
ng iba't ibang computation.
Para gawin iyon, gagamitin natin
ang kahulugan na ito para sa laki ng isang circuit.
Ang kahulugang ito ay gumagana para sa parehong
Boolean at quantum circuit at ito ay napaka-simple.
Ang laki ng isang circuit ay ang
kabuuang bilang ng mga gate nito.
Halimbawa, kung babalikan natin
ang parehong halimbawa na nakita natin nang maraming beses, na ang ating Boolean circuit para sa pag-compute ng exclusive OR ng dalawang bit,
makikita natin na ito ay may laki na pito
dahil mayroon pitong gate, dalawang FANOUT gate, dalawang NOT gate,
dalawang AND gate at isang OR gate. Kung napagdesyunan nating hindi bilangin
ang mga FANOUT gate, na karaniwan, mayroon itong laki na katumbas ng lima,
ngunit biibilang natin ang mga FANOUT gate, kaya ang laki nito ay pito.
Ang laki ng isang circuit
ay tumutugma sa bilang ng mga elementary na operasyon
na kailangan nating gawin.
Kaya kung isasagawa natin
ang mga operasyong iyon nang sunod-sunod, ang laki ay magsasabi
sa atin kung gaano katagal ito,
kaya maaari kang mag-isip tungkol sa laki ng circuit bilang kumakatawan sa sequential na oras ng pagpapatakbo.
Ito ang magiging paraan natin ng
pagsukat ng computational na gastos para sa mga layunin ng araling ito.
Mayroon ding isa pang katangian
ng mga circuit na maaari ring tiningnan bilang halaga ng oras
na kinakailangan para patakbuhin ang isang circuit, at iyon ay ang depth ng circuit.
Sa katumpakan, ang depth
ay ang maximum na bilang ng mga gate na nakatagpo sa anumang landas mula sa isang input wire hanggang sa isang output wire,
na katumbas ng bilang ng mga layer ng mga gate na kailangan nating
likhain ang circuit, kung saan ang isang layer ay tumutukoy sa isang grupo ng mga gate
na maaaring isagawa nang sabay-sabay dahil wala silang
anumang karaniwang wire.
Halimbawa, ang ating circuit
mula kanina ay may depth na apat, at maaari nating makita nang direkta mula sa diagram na mayroon apat na layer.
Ang mga FANOUT gate ay maaaring
isagawa nang sabay-sabay, ang mga NOT gate ay maaaring
isagawa nang sabay-sabay at ang mga AND gate ay maaaring
isagawa nang sabay-sabay din.
Kaya maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa circuit depth bilang kumakatawan sa parallel na oras ng pagpapatakbo.
Ang circuit depth ay tiyak na isang kawili-wili at mahalagang konsepto at mayroon ilang napaka-
sopistikadong mga teknik na maaaring gamitin para bawasan
ang depth na kinakailangan para sa ilang mga computation, kung minsan ay nang husto talaga, ngunit ito ay isang advanced na paksa
at hindi na tayo gagawa ng masyadong maraming karagdagan tungkol dito sa serye.
Kaya muli, susukalin natin
ang computational na gastos sa mga tuntunin ng circuit
laki o sa madaling salita,
ang bilang ng mga elementary na operasyon na kinakailangan para magsagawa ng isang computation.
Sa simula ng aralin, napag-usapan natin ang integer
factorization problem at nakita natin na ang oras na kinakailangan para sa isang algorithm na malutas ang problemang ito
ay maaaring tumaas habang lumalaki ang mga input sa haba, at ito ang karaniwang
isyu na pinag-iipon-ipon natin
kapag nag-aanalisa ng mga algorithm.
Ibig sabihin, interesado tayo sa kung paano nagbe-scale ang mga gastos ng pagpapatakbo ng mga algorithm habang lumalaki at lumalaki ang mga input.
Siyempre, ang uri ng scaling na ito ay hindi ang tanging bagay na mahalaga.
Halimbawa, maaaring interesado lang tayo sa paghahanap ng mga salik
ng RSA1024 at iyon na ang katapusan.
Kaya sa ganoong kaso, pag-uusapan natin ang isang
solong instansya ng problema kung saan walang lumalaki.
Ngunit kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa mga algorithm, ang paraan ng pag-scale ng kanilang mga gastos ay napakahalaga at nagsasabi sa atin ng marami
tungkol sa mga algorithm.
Ang pananaw na ito ay
konsistente sa ideya na ang mga algorithm ay pundamental, at tulad ng napag-usapan ko kanina,
habang tumatagal at umuunlad ang teknolohiya, sila ay ide-deploy laban sa
mas malalaki at mas malalaking input.
Ngunit pansinin na habang ang mga input sa mga computational na problema
ay maaaring lumaki sa laki, ang mga circuit ay hindi lumalaki.
Ang bawat circuit ay may fixed na laki.
At dahil sa dahilan na iyon, kung gusto nating ilarawan ang isang
algorithm gamit ang mga circuit, kailangan nating magkaroon ng pamilya ng mga circuit para gawin iyon,
at sa isang pamilya ng mga circuit, ibig sabihin namin ang isang koleksyon ng mga circuit na nagiging mas malaki at mas malaki para mapangasiwaan ang mga input
habang lumalaki at lumalaki ang mga ito. Halimbawa, isaalang-alang natin ang isang classical deterministic na algorithm
para sa integer factorization problem, marahil isa na batay sa trial division, ngunit ang mga partikular ay hindi talagang mahalaga
para sa halimbawang ito.
Maaari nating sa prinsipyo
ilarawan ang ganoong algorithm gamit ang isang pamilya ng mga Boolean circuit kung saan kung gusto nating mag-factor ng isang numero
na ang binary representation ay may N-bits, kinukuha natin ang circuit CN mula sa ating pamilya at inilagay ang numero
na gusto nating i-factor
sa mga input bit ng circuit na iyon.
Minsan maaari tayong pumiling parameterize ang mga
circuit sa iba't ibang paraan, kaya maaaring hindi laging ang kaso na ang Nth circuit ay may N input bit,
ngunit iyon ay isang medyo karaniwang paraan para gawin ito. Siyempre, habang lumalaki ang mga haba ng input, inaasahan nating magiging mas malaki ang mga circuit
sa pamilyang ito
na sumasalamin sa katotohanan na
ang pag-factor ng apat na bit na numero ay mas madali kaysa sa pag-factor ng 1,024 bit na numero, halimbawa.
At kaya, nang may iyon sa isip, sinusukat natin ang gastos ng ganoong
algorithm sa pamamagitan ng isang function, na nagsasabi sa atin kung ilan
ang mga elementary na operasyon
na kailangan natin para sa bawat posibleng haba ng input, at magagawa natin ito para sa parehong classical at quantum algorithms.
Bilang isang halimbawa, isaalang-alang natin ang problema ng integer addition, na tiyak na mas
simple kaysa sa factoring
o kahit pag-compute ng mga GCD.
Para panatilihing simple, ipagpalagay nating parehong N at
M ay mga hindi-negatibong integer at sila ay kinakatawan
ng mga binary string na may parehong haba.
Paano tayo makakatayo ng mga Boolean circuit na magdadagdag ng dalawang numerong ito nang magkasama?
Simula tayo sa isang algorithm, ang karaniwang algorithm para sa addition, na ang base two analog ng pamamaraan
na ipinapalagay kong natututo tayong lahat para sa pagdaragdag ng mga numero nang magkasama gamit ang
lapis at piraso ng papel, kaya nagsisimula tayo sa
pinakamababang makabuluhang bit,
dinadagdag ang mga ito nang magkasama, at iyon ay nagbibigay sa atin ng pinaka-
makabuluhang bit ng resulta kasama ang isang carry bit
na kailangan nating isaalang-alang
kapag lumipat tayo sa susunod na posisyon. At nagpapatuloy tayong lumipat sa mga bit, naglilikha ng output bits
kasama ang mga carry bit
hanggang sa makarating tayo sa katapusan.
Ang pamamaraang ito ay maaaring
ipahayag nang medyo direkta sa mga tuntunin ng mga Boolean circuit.
Isang paraan para isipin ito ay magsimula sa isang maliit na circuit para sa pagdaragdag ng dalawang single bit integer nang magkasama.
Iyon ay magbibigay sa atin ng isang numero
sa pagitan ng zero at dalawa, kung saan ang mas makabuluhang bit ay ang XOR ng mga input bit
at ang mas makabuluhang bit, o ang carry bit kung gusto mo, ay ang AND ng dalawang input bit.
Minsan tinutukoy natin ang isang circuit na gumaganap ng dalawang operasyong ito nang magkasama bilang isang half adder.
Iyon ay gumagana nang maayos kapag
dalawa lamang ang input bit, ngunit kung gusto nating magdagdag ng mga integer na may higit sa isang bit bawat isa,
kailangan nating harapin
ang mga carry bit sa ilang paraan.
Kaya ang maaari nating gawin ay i-cascade
ang dalawang half adder nang magkasama at kunin ang OR ng mga
carry bit na naglilikha ng tinatawag na full adder,
na karaniwang isang Boolean circuit para sa pagdaragdag ng tatlong single
bit na numero nang magkasama.
At kapag mayroon na tayong full adder, maaari tayong magdagdag ng mga numero nang magkasama
sa pamamagitan lamang ng pag-cascade, nagpapatuloy mula sa pinakamababang makabuluhang bit
hanggang sa pinaka-makabuluhang bit. Karaniwang ipinapatupad lang natin ang standard addition algorithm gamit ang mga full adder para
pangasiwaan ang mga carry bit.
Kaya ano ang gastos ng computation na ito?
Kailangan natin ng pitong elementary
na gate para sa bawat XOR gate, na nangangahulugang 10 gate para sa isang half adder
at samakatuwid ay 21 gate para sa isang full adder, na dalawang half adder kasama ang isang OR gate.
Kaya sa katapusan ng araw, kung ang ating mga input na numero ay parehong may AND bits, kailangan natin ng isang half adder para sa
pinakamababang makabuluhang bit
at isang full adder para sa bawat iba pang bit, at ang huling resulta ay 21 beses N minus isa plus 10 o 21 N minus 11 gate sa kabuuan.
Kung nagpasya tayo sa ilang dahilan na ayaw naming
bilangin ang mga FANOUT gate at isinama ang mga XOR
gate sa ating gate set, kakailanganin natin ng limang N minus
tatlong gate sa kabuuan.
Maganda na malaman nang eksakto kung ilang gate o elementary na operasyon ang kinakailangan para magsagawa ng iba't ibang computation,
tulad ng nakita natin lang sa integer addition.
At siyempre, kung gusto talaga nating ipatupad ang mga computation na ito, kailangan nating malaman ang mga detalyeng ito.
Ngunit kung palagi tayong gagawa ng ganito karaming detalye, lalo na para sa mas
kumplikadong mga algorithm, mabilis tayong malulubog sa mga detalye
na sa maraming kaso ay may
pangalawang kahalagahan.
Isang paraan para gawing simple ang mga bagay na napaka-karaniwan sa
pagsusuri ng mga algorithm ay ang paggamit ng big-O notation,
na nagbibigay-daan sa atin na ipahayag
at ikumpara ang mga rate ng paglago sa medyo simpleng paraan
na napaka-maginhawa.
At dito makikita mo ang kahulugang sumasaklaw sa notation na ito.
Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayo
ng dalawang function G at H, na maaari nating isipin bilang kumuha ng mga hindi-negatibong integer
na halaga para sa simplisidad,
kahit na hindi talaga iyon kinakailangan. Marahil ang G at H ay kumakatawan sa mga gastos ng iba't ibang computation, halimbawa.
Sasabihin natin na ang G ay big-O ng H, na tradisyonal na nakasulat
gamit ang isang equal sign tulad nito.
Kung ang G ng N ay pinaka-
isang positibong constant C times H ng N, basta ang N ay malaki sapat.
Kaya ito ay tungkol sa kung ano ang
mangyayari kapag ang N ay lumaki.
Sa pormal, ang ibig sabihin ng sapat na malaki ay may pagpipilian ng N zero upang ang inequality ay totoo
kapag ang N ay hindi bababa sa N zero.
Ang susi dito ay ang mga
numerong C at N zero ay fixed.
Maaari silang maging anumang numero sa
lahat, ngunit anuman ang kanilang laki, hindi sila maaaring magbago habang lumalaki ang N.
Kung hindi mo pa nakita ang
ganitong uri ng kahulugan noon, maaaring kailanganin ng ilang sandali para masanay ka dito at mahahanap mo ang mga mapagkukunan
na magpapaliwanag ng konseptong ito
nang mas detalyado kaysa sa
nagagawa ko sa araling ito.
Karaniwang ang ginagawa natin ay piliin
ang function H na maging simple upang ipahayag ang isang bagay tungkol sa kung gaano kabilis lumalaki ang function G.
Halimbawa, ang function na ang halaga ay 17 beses N cubed minus 257
beses N squared plus
65,537 ay big-O ng N cubed, at maaari mong iakma ang
halimbawang ito sa kahulugan
sa pamamagitan ng pagpili ng C at N zero nang naaangkop.
Halimbawa, kung kukuha tayo ng C na katumbas ng 18, makikita natin na
ang expression ay hindi hihigit sa 18 beses N cubed
basta ang N ay sapat na malaki.
Inuugnay ang notation na ito pabalik sa
halimbawa ng integer addition, ang maaari na nating sabihin ngayon ay may pamilya ng mga Boolean circuit
para sa pagdaragdag ng mga hindi-negatibong integer nang magkasama upang ang laki ng N circuit, ibig sabihin ang isa na gumagana
para sa mga input ng haba N
ay big-O ng N. Ang aktwal na laki ng CN
ayon sa ating pagsusuri ay 21 beses N minus 11,
ngunit iyon ay big-O ng N.
Ngayon hindi laging matalino ang pagtatapon ng mga detalye tulad nito, ngunit dito ito ay makatuwiran
dahil inilalantad nito ang mahalagang kalikasan ng standard addition algorithm, na ang gastos nito ay nagbe-scale nang linearly
sa laki ng mga numerong
idinaragdag natin, at ang expression na ito ay hindi sensitibo sa ilang mababang antas na
mga detalye ng ating modelo,
tulad ng eksakto kung aling mga gate ang ituturing nating elementary na operasyon.
Halimbawa, kung napagdesyunan nating ang mga XOR gate ay dapat ituring na
elementary na operasyon o ang mga FANOUT gate ay hindi dapat
bilangin bilang mga gate o pareho,
mayroon pa rin tayong integer addition na maaaring i-compute sa gastos na big-O ng N.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa ng
isang computational na problema, multiplikasyon ng mga integer.
Katulad ng addition, maaari nating itanong kung ano ang gastos
ng computation na ito.
Kung isaalang-alang natin ang karaniwang
multiplication algorithm, ibig sabihin ang base two analog ng pamamaraan para sa pagpaparami ng mga numero
na itinuro sa mga elementarya,
na karaniwang pag-shift at pagdaragdag lamang kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa mga numero sa binary, makikita natin na mayroon mga Boolean circuit na may laki na big-O ng N squared
para sa pagpaparami ng N-bit na mga integer.
Hindi ko ito tatalakayin nang detalyado. Siyempre ang mga circuit ay medyo
mas kumplikado kaysa sa mga para sa addition, ngunit kung iniisip mo ang paraan
ng pagtatrabaho ng karaniwang
multiplication algorithm, hindi dapat nakakagulat.
Sa esensya, kailangan nating
gumawa ng humigit-kumulang N addition, bawat isa ay may linear na gastos, at kaya nakakamit tayo ng
quadratic na gastos sa kabuuan.
Maaari itong gawing pangkalahatan. Kung ang isa sa mga numero ay may N bit at ang isa pa ay may N bit, kailangan natin ng mga circuit ng
laki na big-O ng N times M.
Dito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, gumagamit talaga tayo ng extension ng big-O notation kung saan mayroon tayong maramihang mga variable, ngunit maaari itong palawakin nang ganito,
at kung interesado ka
sa mga partikular na detalye, ire-refer kita sa textbook
na nilalaman para sa aralin, na muling naka-link sa
paglalarawan ng video.
Posible talaga
na paramihin ang dalawang N-bit integer sa isang paraan
na asymptotically mas mahusay kaysa sa karaniwang multiplication algorithm.
Partikular, ang Schonhage-Strassen multiplication algorithm
ay nagpaparami ng dalawang N-bit integer na may gastos na big-O ng
N times ang haba ng N
times ang haba ng haba ng N. Kaya habang lumalaki ang N, tulad ng
sampung libo ng mga bit,
ito ay talagang isang mas
mahusay na paraan para magparami, ngunit ito ay kumplikado at ang overhead ay nagpapaimpraktikal nito
para sa mas maliliit na numero.
Kaya idagdag natin ang multiplikasyon
sa ating listahan ng mga halimbawa.
At para sa simplisidad, ilista natin ang gastos na ibinibigay ng karaniwang multiplication algorithm, na big-O ng N squared.
Kaya muli, nagtutuon tayo sa mahalagang kalikasan ng gastos na ito, na nagbe-scale ito nang quadratically
o sub-quadratically kung gumagamit tayo ng asymptotically mas mahusay na mga pamamaraan.
Maaari rin nating isaalang-alang ang
problema ng integer division, na nakalagay nang tumpak sa screen.
Dito pag-uusapan natin ang pag-compute ng isang quotient at isang remainder, kaya ang sagot ay binubuo
ng dalawang integer, Q at R.
Muli, mayroon isang karaniwang
algorithm para sa division at mayroon din itong quadratic
na gastos at tulad ng multiplikasyon,
mayroon talagang asymptotically
mas mahusay na mga algorithm.
Kaya paano nagtatanggal ang mga GCD algorithm?
Ang Euclid's algorithm ay lumalabas
na may quadratic na gastos, at iyon ang ibig sabihin ko
kanina sa aralin nang sinabi kong maaari nating i-compute ang mga GCD
sa halos parehong gastos ng pagpaparami ng dalawang numero nang magkasama.
Muli, mayroon
asymptotically mas mahusay na mga algorithm na katulad ng linya sa
addition at multiplikasyon,
kahit ang gastos ay medyo
mas mataas sa kasong ito, kahit sa alam natin.
Banggitin ko ang isa pang halimbawa ng problema para idagdag sa listahang ito, at iyon ay ang modular exponentiation.
Dito mayroon tatlong input
na numero, K, M, at N, at ang layunin ay i-compute
ang N sa kapangyarihang K modulo-M,
na nangangahulugang ang remainder
pagkatapos nating hatiin sa M.
Hindi ito malinaw, ngunit maaari nating i-compute ang modular
exponentiation sa qubit na gastos, ibig sabihin big-O ng N cubed
para sa N-bit na mga integer.
Ang paraan para gawin ang isa ay hindi muna i-compute ang N sa kapangyarihang K at pagkatapos ay i-compute ang remainder.
Kahit ang pagsusulat sa kapangyarihang K ay maaaring mangailangan ng exponentially maraming bit, kaya ang pamamaraang iyon ay hindi gagana.
Sa halip, maaari tayong gumamit ng algorithm
na tinatawag na power algorithm, na tinatawag ding repeated squaring kung saan ang lahat ay ginagawa nang modulo-M
at ginagamit natin ang mga bit ng
K para iteratively mag-square at magparami sa paraang
gumagana ang lahat.
Kaya ito ay mas
mahal kaysa sa iba pa, ngunit maaari pa rin nating isagawa
ang modular exponentiation nang mabilis sa mga numero
na may libu-libong bit.
Kaya paano nagtatanggal ang mga gastos ng mga gawaing ito kumpara sa integer factorization?
Kung magsisimula tayo nang simple at
isipin ang trial division kung saan unang tinitingnan natin kung ang dalawa ay salik ng input na numero
at pagkatapos ay titingnan ang tatlo at iba pa, makakakuha tayo ng medyo
mahal na algorithm, big-O ng N squared times
dalawa sa kapangyarihang N over two.
Ang bawat division ay tumatagal ng quadratic na oras at sa pinakamasamang kaso, kailangan nating maghanap ng mga prime factor hanggang sa square root ng input na numero,
at iyon ang pinagmulan ng N
over two. Kung hindi pa natin nahanap ang isang
prime factor sa puntong iyon, maaari na tayong huminto dahil
ang input na numero mismo ay dapat prime.
Ito ay napakamahal dahil ang N ay lumalabas bilang isang exponent sa expression na ito, ibig sabihin, ang
algorithm na ito ay may exponential na gastos.
Sa kaibahan, lahat ng mga halimbawa na mayroon tayo sa kahon na ito ay may tinatawag nating polynomial na gastos kung saan ang N ay itinataas sa isang kapangyarihan,
ngunit ang kapangyarihang iyon ay laging isang fixed na numero na hindi lumalaki habang
lumalaki ang haba ng input.
Sa mga kasong ito, ang mga kapangyarihan
ay isa, dalawa, at tatlo.
Babalik ako sa polynomial kumpara sa exponential na gastos sa ilang sandali, ngunit una, tapusin natin ang
alam natin tungkol sa factoring.
Kanina ay binanggit ko
ang number field sieve, na ang pinakamahusay na
factoring algorithm na mayroon tayo sa mga tuntunin ng paraan ng pag-scale ng gastos nito.
Sa katunayan, ang gastos ng algorithm na ito ay hindi talagang rigorous na napatunayan dahil ito ay konektado sa ilang bukas na tanong tungkol sa number theory,
ngunit ito ay conjectured na magkaroon ng
isang gastos na ganito ang hitsura.
Sa pagkakataong ito ang big-O ay nasa exponent, ngunit isinasamantala ko ang
detalyeng iyon.
Ang pangunahing aral ay ito ay makabuluhang mas mahusay
kaysa sa trial division dahil kahit ang N ay
lumalabas sa exponent,
ito ay itinataas sa kapangyarihang 1/3 at iyon ay nagsasalin sa mas mababang gastos at iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ang algorithm na ito
ay kayang pangasiwaan ang mga numero tulad ng RSA250, samantalang ang trial division
ay tiyak na hindi kaya.
Ito ay exponential pa rin, gayunpaman, sa kahulugang isang kapangyarihan ng N ang lumalabas sa isang exponent, at kaya, bilang resulta,
hindi pa rin nito kayang pangasiwaan
ang mga numero tulad ng RSA1024.
Ngayon sabihin ko pa nang kaunti tungkol sa polynomial na gastos
laban sa exponential na gastos.
Sinasabi nating ang isang algorithm
ay may polynomial na gastos kung ang gastos nito ay big-O ng N sa kapangyarihang B,
kung saan ang B ay maaaring maging anumang positibong numero, ngunit ang susi ay ang B ay dapat fixed, ibig sabihin hindi ito nagbabago
habang lumalaki ang haba ng input.
Para sa mga halimbawang nakita natin kanina, ibig sabihin ang integer addition, multiplikasyon, division, pag-compute ng mga GCD
at modular exponentiation,
mayroon tayong B na katumbas ng
isa, dalawa o tatlo.
Kaya ang lahat ng ito ay
polynomial na gastos na mga algorithm.
Ngunit kapag nagsasalita tayo ng polynomial
na gastos nang mas pangkalahatan, ang B ay maaaring maging anumang positibong numero.
Maaari itong maging isang milyon,
ngunit dapat itong fixed.
Bilang medyo magaspang na abstraksiyon, ang mga algorithm na may polynomial
na gastos ay karaniwang tinuturing na kumakatawan sa mga mahusay na algorithm.
Ito ay tiyak na isang oversimplification, ngunit bilang magaspang na gabay, maaari kang mag-isip tungkol sa isang
polynomial na gastos na algorithm
bilang paggamit ng
istraktura ng problema para mag-construct ng solusyon kumpara sa isang brute
force na uri ng diskarte
o isang exhaustive na paghahanap
sa napakalaking espasyo.
Siyempre, ang isang algorithm na ang gastos ay nagbe-scale bilang N sa isang milyon
sa mga input ng haba N
ay hindi makatwirang
matitingnan bilang mahusay, at hindi natin inaasahan na
matatakbo ito sa malalaking input.
Ngunit pa rin kahit isang N sa
isang milyong algorithm ay dapat gumawa ng isang bagay na matalino na sa ilang paraan ay sumasalamin sa istraktura
ng anumang problema na niresolba nito para maiwasan ang exponential na pag-scale sa gastos na maiuugnay sa
isang exhaustive na paghahanap sa malawak na domain.
At sa praktis, ang pagkilala ng isang polynomial na gastos na algorithm ay isang unang
hakbang lamang tungo sa kahusayan.
Kung ang isang problema ay mahalaga
at natuklasan ng isang tao ang pinaka-unang polynomial
na gastos na algorithm para dito, marahil ay may napakmalaking exponent,
maaari kang maging makatuwirang sigurado na ang mga algorithm designer
ay makakahanap ng mga pagpapabuti na magpapababa ng exponent na iyon.
Sa esensya, maaari kang
mag-isip tungkol sa pag-iral ng isang polynomial na gastos
na algorithm para sa isang problema bilang nagpapakita ng katuparan
ng paglutas ng problemang iyon
sa makatwirang malalaking input, ngunit maaaring may marami pang trabaho na kailangan para maabot ang tunay na kahusayan.
Sa complexity theory, karaniwang sinasabi na ang gastos ng isang algorithm
ay nagbe-scale nang sub-exponentially kung ang gastos ay big-O ng dalawa sa kapangyarihang N
sa kapangyarihang epsilon para sa bawat positibong tunay na numero epsilon, at kung hindi ito sub-exponential,
kung gayon ito ay exponential, o maaaring kahit super-exponential tulad ng dalawa sa dalawa sa N,
na doubly exponential,
ngunit basta ang output
ay hindi super-exponentially mahaba, ang bawat problema ay maaari talagang
i-compute ng isang Boolean circuit
na may exponential na gastos tulad ng lumalabas. Kaya ang mahalagang pagkakaiba dito ay sa pagitan ng polynomial
at exponential na gastos.
Hindi tayo nakakaalam ng anumang sub-exponential na gastos na classical algorithms para sa
integer factorization.
Halimbawa, ang gastos ng number field sieve ay hindi big-O ng dalawa sa
kapangyarihang N sa epsilon kapag ang epsilon ay 1/3 o mas kaunti,
kaya hindi nito nasasatisfy ang kahulugang ito.
Ito ay walang duda na isang napaka-matalinong algorithm, ngunit ito ay sieve pa rin at tayo ay epektibong naghahanap pa rin
sa napakalaking espasyo para tukuyin ang mga salik ng isang ibinigay na numero.
Tulad ng makikita natin sa susunod na aralin, mayroon talagang isang polynomial
na gastos na quantum algorithm para sa integer factorization.
Ang Shor's algorithm ay may polynomial na gastos at partikular na mayroon itong qubit na gastos, katulad ng modular exponentiation.
Isa pang klase ng mga problema na
maaaring pamilyar ka ay ang klase ng mga NP-complete na problema.
Hindi ko tatalakayin kung ano ang mga NP-complete na problema sa araling ito, ngunit maaari mong hanapin ang mga ito
kung interesado ka.
Conjectured na
wala sa mga problema na ito ang may sub-exponential na gastos.
Iyon ay karaniwang isang circuit-based na bersyon ng kung minsan ay tinatawag na
exponential time hypothesis, ngunit hanggang ngayon ay walang nakakaroon ng paraan para patunayan ito.
Sa katunayan, hindi natin kahit mapatunayan na walang linear na gastos na mga algorithm para sa mga NP-complete na problema.
Ito ay napaka-mahirap talaga, kahit sa alam natin, na ibukod ang posibilidad
ng isang hinaharap na pagtuklas ng isang hindi kapani-paniwalang creative
na algorithm para sa mga problemang ito.
Narito ang isang figure na
naglalarawan ng relasyon sa pagitan ng polynomial at exponential na gastos.
Sa X axis, mayroon tayo ang haba ng input sa anumang problema na iniisip natin, at ang Y axis ay kumakatawan sa
gastos ng paglutas ng problemang iyon
o maaari kang mag-isip tungkol
dito bilang oras na kinakailangan para malutas ang problema kung gusto mo.
Ang isang exponential na gastos na algorithm
ay maaaring mag-scale nang ganito.
Para sa maikling input, ang gastos ay maaaring hindi mataas, tulad ng pag-factor ng
numero 12, halimbawa,
ngunit habang lumalaki ang haba ng input, ang gastos ay sa huli ay mag-eexplode.
Ang isang polynomial na gastos na algorithm,
sa kabilang banda, ay maaaring may scaling na ganito ang hitsura.
Ang gastos ay mataas pa rin sa pangkalahatan habang lumalaki ang mga input, at maaari pa itong maghalaga nang higit pa kaysa sa exponential na gastos
na algorithm para sa ilang input,
ngunit sa huli ito ay
mas mababa ang halaga kaysa sa exponential na gastos na algorithm at hindi ito nagpe-pero sa parehong matinding paraan
na ginagawa ng mga exponential na gastos na algorithm.
Kaya kung iniisip natin na mayroon tayong ilang maximum na gastos na handang gastusin natin, o isang maximum na dami ng oras na handang hintayin natin para sa isang sagot,
kung gusto mong isipin ito bilang oras, kung gayon ang exponential na gastos na algorithm ay gagana lamang para sa mga input
hanggang sa isang ibinigay na haba,
samantalang, sa pangkalahatan, ang
polynomial na gastos na algorithm ay magbibigay-daan sa atin na malutas ang
problema para sa mas malalaking input.
At iyon ang dahilan kung bakit, halimbawa, madali nating mai-compute ang mga GCD para sa mga numero na may libu-libong
bit, ngunit sa pinakamasamang kaso,
hindi natin ma-factor ang mga numero ng ganitong laki.
Sa huling bahagi ng aralin, itutuon natin ang ating pansin sa pagpapatupad ng mga classical computation
sa mga quantum computer.
Mas partikular, makikita natin
na ang anumang computation na maaaring isagawa ng isang Boolean circuit ay maaari ring isagawa ng isang quantum circuit
sa halos parehong gastos. Bukod dito, maaari itong
gawin sa isang malinis na paraan na mahalaga kung gusto
nating patakbuhin ang mga computation na ito
bilang mga subroutine sa loob ng
mas malalaking quantum computation, at ipapaliwanag ko kung ano ang ibig sabihin ng malinis kapag mas nalayo na ang talakayan.
Gagamitin natin ang mga
Toffoli gate sa prosesong ito.
Alalahanin na ang mga Toffoli gate ay mga controlled-controlled-NOT gate, kaya ang kanilang aksyon sa mga standard basis state
ay tulad ng nakikita mo dito sa screen.
Pansinin na maaari rin nating
isipin ang mga Toffoli gate bilang katulad ng mga query gate
para sa AND function.
Hindi sinasabi nito na ang mga ito ay mga query gate sa literal na kahulugan. Tulad ng binanggit ko sa simula ng aralin, hindi tayo nagtatrabaho sa loob ng
query model sa puntong ito,
kundi ang kanilang aksyon ay sumusunod sa parehong pattern ng isang query gate.
Maaari nating isipin ang mga binary na halaga A at B bilang mga input sa AND function at tulad ng isang query gate,
ang mga halagang ito ay echo
bilang bahagi ng output at ang halaga ng function, ibig sabihin ang logical AND ng A at B
ay naka-XOR sa ibabaw ng ibabang qubit. Ngayon, hindi natin isinama ang mga Toffoli gate sa ating standard gate set.
Maaari tayong magbago ng isip kung gusto natin, ngunit hindi talaga natin kailangan na
gawin iyon dahil bilang alternatibo, maaari nating ipatupad ang mga Toffoli
gate gamit ang mga Hadamard gate,
T at T dagger gate
at mga controlled NOT gate tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Hindi malinaw
na ang partikular na circuit na ito ay nagpapatupad ng isang Toffoli gate, ngunit ginagawa nito, at maaari kang magtiwala sa akin
o paramihin ang lahat nang ikaw mismo para makakuha ng karagdagang pagsasanay, o maaari kang magtanong sa Qiskit o Python
o anumang software na nagpaparami ng mga matrices para gawin ang multiplikasyon para sa iyo.
At maaari mong tingnan ang
textbook na nilalaman para sa aralin para makita itong ginagawa gamit ang Qiskit.
Ngayon maaari na tayong lumipat sa pag-simulate ng mga Boolean gate gamit ang mga quantum circuit at lahat ng kakailanganin natin para gawin ito ay ang mga NOT gate,
mga controlled NOT gate at Toffoli gate.
Ang mga operasyong ito ay lahat deterministic bilang karagdagan sa pagiging unitary at kung minsan ay inilalarawan natin
ang mga operasyon tulad nito bilang reversible, at sa katunayan,
ang pag-aaral ng reversible na computation ay nauna sa quantum computing at iyon ang pinagmulan ng buong
pamamaraang ito.
Ang mga Boolean gate na kailangan nating
pag-alabalahin ay ang mga NOT gate, Hadamard gate at FANOUT gate,
At ang ipapakita natin ay maaari nating ipatupad ang mga gate na ito, o i-simulate ang mga ito kung
gusto mo, gamit ang mga NOT gate,
mga controlled NOT gate at Toffoli gate.
Para maging malinaw, ang gusto natin ay mga quantum circuit na nagbibigay-daan sa atin na i-compute ang mga halaga ng mga Boolean gate na binanggit ko lang
kapag binibigyan natin ang mga ito ng mga qubit sa
mga standard basis state bilang input.
Para sa mga arbitrary na quantum state input, ang aksyon ay matutukoy
ng linearity tulad ng dati.
Hindi natin kailangang gumawa ng anumang
espesyal sa mga NOT gate. Ang mga NOT gate ay mga NOT gate at maaari silang ipatupad nang direkta.
At ang mga OR gate ay maaaring i-simulate
gamit ang mga Toffoli at NOT gate.
Ang mga AND gate ay madali, partikular sa liwanag ng sinabi ko kanina tungkol sa mga Toffoli gate na karaniwang
mga query gate na implementasyon
ng AND function.
Para maging tumpak, ang maaari nating gawin ay magpakilala ng bagong qubit na nakapaloob sa zero state
at hayaan ang qubit na iyon na maging
target ng ating Toffoli gate at hayaan ang dalawang input
qubit na maging mga kontrol.
Iba't ibang pangalan ang ibinibigay
sa mga karagdagang qubit tulad nito, na madalas na ipinapakilala
sa mga quantum computation at tatawagin ko silang workspace
qubit para pumili ng pangalan.
Ang ating karaniwang pagpapalagay sa mga workspace qubit ay nagsisimula sila sa zero state at maaari nating minsanang ibalik
ang mga ito sa zero state
kapag tapos na tayo sa mga ito, ngunit hindi palagi.
Sa diagram mayroon tayong cat zero sa loob ng dotted na parihaba para ipahiwatig na ang
initialization ng qubit na ito
ay bahagi ng proseso, at kung wala kang
sariwang qubit tulad nito, hindi mo magagawa
ang simulation na ito.
Ang ibabang output qubit
ay ang pinagmamalasakitan natin dahil iyon ang resulta
ng AND na operasyon at karaniwang
tapos na tayo sa iba pang dalawa
kaya maaari silang manatili sa loob ng kahon.
Sa katunayan, maaari kang kahit isipin na ang pag-aalis ng dalawang qubit na ito ay bahagi ng trabaho ng
pag-simulate ng AND gate na ito,
parang basura na
kailangang linisin.
Ngunit saan man naroroon, iyon ay kung paano natin
maaaring i-simulate ang isang AND gate.
Ngayong alam na natin kung paano gumawa ng mga AND gate, maaari tayong gumawa ng mga OR gate gamit ang
isa sa mga batas ni De Morgan.
Kung maglagay ka ng mga NOT gate sa dalawang input sa output ng isang AND
gate, makakakuha ka ng isang OR gate, kaya simple lang iyon.
At ang huling isa ay FANOUT, at para dito, kailangan lang natin ng isang controlled NOT gate kasama ang isang workspace qubit.
Partikular, kung
itakda natin ang workspace qubit na maging target, epektibong kinokopya lang natin ang anumang standard basis state na papasok,
kaya iyon ay kumakakilos tulad ng isang FANOUT gate.
Kaya mayroon na tayo ng lahat ng ating mga gate.
At ngayong mayroon na tayong lahat ng ating mga gate, maaari tayong lumipat sa mga circuit.
Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayo
ng ilang Boolean circuit na pinangalanang C, at maaari ito maging anumang
Boolean circuit na gusto mo
basta ito ay binubuo ng
mga AND o NOT at FANOUT gate.
Hayaan nating T ang maging bilang ng mga gate sa C at bibigyan natin ng pangalang F ang anumang function na kino-compute ng C.
Kaya maaari nating isipin ang F bilang may form na makikita mo dito, kung saan ang N ay ang bilang ng input bits ng C,
ang M ay ang bilang ng output bits at ang sigma ay ang binary alphabet.
At ang ginagawa natin ay isa-isa na dumaan sa mga gate ng C.
Iniwan natin ang mga NOT gate nang walang bago at pinapalitan natin ang iba pa ng mga simulation
na iyon lamang ang aking inilarawan.
Kaya kung ang C ay ganito ang hitsura, kung gayon ang nakukuha natin ay isang circuit
R na ganito ang hitsura.
Sa diagram na ito, lahat
ng workspace qubit na kailangan natin para sa mga simulation ay kinuha mula sa kanilang mga kahon at nakolekta sa ibaba.
Kaya ang K ay ang kabuuang bilang ng
workspace qubit na kailangan natin, na isa para sa bawat gate ng C maliban sa mga NOT gate.
Para sa output ng R, mayroon tayo ng mga qubit na
tumutugma sa output ng C, at dito ang mga qubit na iyon
ay inilalarawan sa itaas,
kahit na hindi talagang mahalaga sa katapusan ng lahat ng ito
kung nasa itaas sila o hindi.
Para maging tumpak, ipagpalagay na pinatakbo natin ang R sa isang standard basis state na tumutugma sa isang
arbitrary na N-bit string X,
ang M output qubit na ito ay magiging sa standard basis state
na tumutugma sa F ng X.
Mayroon din tayong lahat ng mga natitirang qubit mula sa mga AND at OR gate.
Kailangan pa rin nating pag-alalahanin ang mga ito, at kung titipunin natin ang lahat ng mga ito, sila ay magiging sa ilang standard basis state.
Anuman ang standard basis state ay dapat maging ilang function ng string X, at bibigyan natin
ng pangalang G ang function na iyon.
Kaya ang G ay isang bagong function na
tinutukoy ng mga gate ng C na nagsasabi sa atin kung anong estado
ang mga natitirang qubit na ito
pagkatapos patakbuhin ang R. Ang G ay ang susunod na titik pagkatapos ng F, kaya iyon ay isang dahilan para
tawaging G ang function na ito,
ngunit isa pang dahilan para tawaging G ito ay dahil ang G ay maikli para sa basura.
Ang lahat ng mga ito ay mga garbage qubit, at partikular, mayroon tayong
dalawang garbage qubit para sa bawat AND gate at para sa bawat OR gate.
Ang kabuuang bilang ng mga gate
na kailangan natin ay big-O ng T.
Iyon ay dahil para sa bawat gate ng C, kailangan natin ng isang bounded na bilang ng mga quantum gate.
Ang OR gate ang pinaka-mahal. Para doon, kailangan natin ng tatlong NOT gate kasama ang isang Toffoli gate,
at ang isang Toffoli gate ay nagkakahalaga sa atin ng 15 gate mula sa ating standard gate set.
Kaya iyon ay pinaka-18 gate
sa R para sa bawat gate ng C.
Kung gusto mong i-optimize ito, magagawa mo, ngunit para sa mga layunin ng
isang magaspang na asymptotic na pagsusuri, masasabi lang nating
ang R ay may big-O ng T gates.
Kaya nagawa nating
i-compute ang parehong function F na kinompute ng orihinal na Boolean
circuit C,
at ginawa natin ito sa isang gastos na linear sa laki ng C.
Kung ang lahat ng pinag-iipon natin ay
ang pag-compute ng function F na ito, tapos na tayo.
Ngunit sa kasamaang palad, mayroon tayo
ng mga garbage qubit na ito at ang mga garbage qubit na ito
ay karaniwang sisirahin
ang mga interference pattern na nagpapatakbo ng mga quantum algorithm kung susubukan nating gamitin ang
circuit R na ito bilang isang subroutine
sa loob ng isang mas malaking quantum algorithm.
Ngunit maaari talaga nating
alisin ang basurang ito, at ang paraan para magawa natin ito ay gamitin ang katotohanan na ang circuit R ay maaaring i-invert,
o sa madaling salita, maaari
nating patakbuhin ito nang pabaligtad.
Para ilarawan kung paano ito gumagana, isipin natin na una nating pinapatakbo ang R at pagkatapos ay pinapatakbo natin ang R nang pabaligtad,
na maaari nating ipahayag bilang R dagger.
Para maging malinaw tungkol dito, ang ibig sabihin nito ay inilalapat natin ang mga gate ng
R nang baligtad na pagkakasunud-sunod at kinukuha natin ang mga inverse
ng bawat gate.
Ang mga NOT gate, controlled NOT
gate at Toffoli gate ay talagang sariling inverse ng mga ito, kaya kung nag-iisip tayo sa mga
tuntunin ng mga gate na ito,
kung gayon ang R dagger ay talagang R lamang na may mga gate na ibinibigay
sa baligtad na pagkakasunud-sunod.
Ngunit sa pangkalahatan, maaari nating palaging patakbuhin ang anumang unitary quantum circuit nang pabaligtad sa paraang inilarawan ko,
ibig sabihin, inilalapat natin ang
mga gate nang baligtad na pagkakasunud-sunod at pinapalitan natin ang bawat isa sa mga
indibidwal na gate ng inverse nito.
Kung gagawin natin ito, makikita nating ang unang pagpapatakbo ng R at pagkatapos ay pagpapatakbo ng R nang
pabaligtad ay walang ginagawa.
Kaya kung nagsimula tayo sa isang standard basis state tulad ng mayroon tayo dito, kung gayon magtatapos tayo sa eksakto parehong standard basis state.
Siyempre, ang paggawa lang
nito ay hindi masyadong kapaki-pakinabang, ngunit ang maaari nating gawin ay maaari tayong magpakilala ng isang grupo ng mga karagdagang qubit at partikular,
ito ay M qubit kung saan ang M ay ang bilang ng output bits ng circuit C.
Ang mga karagdagang qubit na ito ay maaaring
nasa anumang quantum state, ngunit para ipaliwanag kung paano ito gumagana, ipagpalagay natin na sila ay nasa isang standard basis state
na tumutugma sa ilang string Y. Kaya ang Y ay isang M-bit string, at ang maaari nating gawin ay magsagawa ng
isang grupo ng mga controlled NOT
gate tulad ng makikita mo dito, na epektibong nag-XOR ng string F ng X
sa string Y na nakaimbak
sa mga ibabang M qubit na ito.
At kaya ang output ng
buong computation ay tulad ng lumabas sa screen.
Ang X at Y ay mga arbitrary na binary string. Ang X ay may M-bits at ang Y ay may M-bits, at kailangan din natin ng K workspace qubit.
Kapag pinatakbo natin ang R, kino-compute natin ang F ng X at ang string na iyon ay nakaimbak
sa mga nangungunang M qubit, ngunit mayroon din tayong isang grupo ng mga garbage qubit,
kaya nag-XOR tayo ng output F ng
X sa mga ibabang M qubit at pagkatapos ay pinapatakbo ang R nang pabaligtad
para linisin ang basura.
Dapat kong ituro na mahalaga na ang R ay deterministic.
Kung ang mga nangungunang M qubit na ito ay sa halip ay nasa ilang superposition ng
mga standard basis na estado, hindi ito gagana nang tama,
ngunit ito ay gumagana kapag
ang R ay deterministic.
Kaya kung ikukumpara natin ang quantum
circuit na katatapos lang nating itayo sa orihinal na Boolean circuit C, makikita natin na karaniwang gumagana ito sa parehong paraan
na gumagana ang isang query gate
para sa isang arbitrary na function.
Mayroon isang pagkakaiba dito, na kailangan natin
ng mga workspace qubit na ito para gumana ang lahat, ngunit kung hindi man ay epektibo tayong nagtatayo ng isang query gate
o isang query circuit para sa anumang function na kino-compute ng C.
Nagawa rin natin, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, na ibalik ang mga workspace
qubit sa kanilang paunang estado, kaya maaari silang sa prinsipyo ay muling gamitin
bilang mga workspace qubit para
sa mga kasunod na computation.
Kung gusto natin, maaari tayong maglagay ng kahon sa paligid ng buong quantum circuit at tawagin itong Q at ang relasyon sa
C ay magiging mas malinaw.
Ang circuit Q ay magiging
mas malaki kaysa sa C sa pangkalahatan. Kailangan natin ng ilang quantum
gate sa Q para sa bawat gate ng C,
at kailangan din natin ang mga controlled
NOT gate sa gitna, ngunit ang bilang ay linear pa rin
sa laki ng C.
Dapat ding ituro na ito ay isang ganap na pangkalahatang pamamaraan na gumagana para sa anumang Boolean circuit, at hindi tayo nagsisikap na i-optimize ang Q.
Para sa isang partikular na circuit C, maaaring mayroon
mga paraan para bawasan ang laki ng Q, at kasama rito ang paggamit ng mga pamamaraan
na nagbabawas ng bilang ng
mga workspace qubit na kailangan sa kaso na iyon
ang isang bagay na gusto nating gawin, at iyon ang pamamaraan para sa pagpapatakbo ng
mga classical computation
sa isang quantum computer.
Ito ay medyo simple, ngunit ito ay isang mahalagang
bagay na magagawa.
Partikular, ngayong
alam na natin kung paano gawin ito, malaya na tayong gumamit ng anumang classical computation na gusto natin
sa loob ng mga quantum computation, basta sinusunod natin ang form na ito kung saan ang input ay ine-echo at ang output ay naka-XOR
sa isang grupo ng mga qubit
tulad ng mayroon tayo para sa mga query gate.
Ang gastos ay nagbe-scale nang linearly. Kaya halimbawa, maaari tayong
lumikha ng mga quantum circuit para sa mga problema tulad ng integer addition,
multiplikasyon, division, pag-compute ng mga GCD at modular exponentiation, at lahat ito ay maaaring gawin sa parehong asymptotic na gastos
tulad ng para sa mga Boolean circuit.
Kailangan natin ng mga workspace qubit para gawin ito, ngunit kahit paano ay available ang mga ito para muling gamitin kapag
tapos na tayo sa mga ito.
Isang huling puna na sulit banggitin ay ang pamamaraang ito ay nagbibigay sa atin ng isang paraan para ipatupad ang mga query gate,
na binalangkas ko sa nakaraang aralin.
Ibig sabihin, kung mayroon tayong isang query algorithm na kumukuha ng ilang function F bilang input, at mayroon tayong paraan para i-compute
ang F gamit ang isang Boolean circuit,
maaari nating sundin ang pamamaraang ito para bumuo ng isang query gate para sa function na iyon at pagkatapos ay patakbuhin ang ating query algorithm dito.
Kung kapaki-pakinabang man ito o hindi ay depende sa query problem mismo at kung ano ang sinisikap nating gawin, ngunit sa esensya, ang
konstruksiyon na ito ay nagbibigay sa atin
ng isang paraan ng pag-uugnay ng query model sa isang mas karaniwang modelo ng computation.
Sa ilang kahulugan ito ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng Shor's algorithm para sa integer factorization.
Magtatayo tayo
ng mga quantum circuit tulad nito mula sa ilan sa mga arithmetic na operasyon na napag-usapan natin kanina sa aralin.
At sa pamamagitan ng paggawa niyon, binibigyan natin
ang mga quantum circuit ng kakayahang suriin ang mga operasyong iyon sa mga superposition ng mga classical state.
At tulad ng makikita natin, iyon ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na mag-factor ng mga integer nang mahusay.
Iyon ang katapusan ng araling ito, na pangunahing nakatuon sa pagtatatag ng isang pundasyon
para sa mga quantum algorithm sa isang karaniwang hindi-black box
na computational framework.
Napag-usapan natin ang computational na gastos pangunahin sa pamamagitan ng lens ng mga problema na konektado sa pangunahing number theory.
Tinalakay natin ang polynomial
laban sa exponential na gastos para sa mga computational na gawain, at nakita natin kung paano ang mga classical computation
ay maaaring ipatupad ng mga quantum circuit sa isang malinis na walang-basura na paraan na nagbibigay-daan sa mga ito na gamitin bilang mga subroutine
sa loob ng mas malalaking quantum computation.
Umaasa akong sasama ka sa akin para sa susunod na aralin kung saan makikita natin kung paano ginagamit ng Shor's algorithm ang mga ideyang ito, na nagbibigay-daan sa atin na mag-factorize
ng mga integer sa polynomial na gastos.
Paalam hanggang sa susunod.